and with me now is the former labour
leader jeremy corbyn and mp uh mr corbyn
just explained to me exactly what you
are calling for here today
pno have received a lot of money from
the government during covid they get a
lot of government contracts they behaved
in a disgusting and disgraceful way by
sacking 800 workers what we're demanding
the government is immediate intervention
to say to pno stop that action reinstate
those 800 workers and if you don't do
that
we'll take over your assets and we will
prevent you operating as a company you
cannot allow
a famous name an iconic company like pno
to behave like this in modern britain
and call it a civilized modern nation
well the government has already warned
of course of ramifications for piano
ferries they say they are investigating
what is happening seeing uh whether it
actually uh is legal do you not think
they're doing enough i don't think
they're doing enough at all the minister
saying he has sympathies but doesn't
have powers the government said they're
looking at the ramifications the
ramifications are 800 people have lost
their jobs families in lan in liverpool
in harley dover in london are wondering
what the future holds and a group of
other people have been brought in
on worse conditions worse wages we don't
know what qualifications they have we
don't know what the safety is going to
be like on these vessels in the future
and this company at the same time has
money to throw at golf and formula one
this is a contrast of what the way this
company behaves i think what we need is
the government saying pretty bluntly to
them if you don't get your house in
order and become a decent fair and
reasonable employer like you should be
then we will take you over
we've heard the labour party today
saying that they are calling for the
removal of dp world from the
government's transport advisory group
the clawing back of government covered
support given to dp world the outlawing
of fire and rehire are you happy with
the labour party's response overall and
secure stamina's response or is there
more that you would have them do that is
a good start and it is a very good start
but at the end of the day if that
doesn't work we've got to go further
than that look this is an island nation
we are a seafaring nation we're a
trading nation we need transport we need
ships and we need them to be safely and
properly crewed we need staff that are
properly paid and employed upon them and
i think we should be prepared to say
well if piano are not going to prepare
to do the job properly we will then make
it a publicly owned company and run it
properly
we've also heard kind of noises today
about some possible legal action about
this from the unions what form could
that take well the form i think could be
to demand a legal intervention to
restrain piano from
sacking the workers that they've done it
could also be on the basis that was no
information given to the workforce and
no consultation taken and so it will be
up for legal advice that's going to be
taken but i would imagine that the rmt a
very experienced very effective trade
union will be talking to their lawyers
at the moment to make sure that action
is taken in all fronts it's going to be
industrial action it's going to be
demonstration it's going to be in
parliament it's also going to be legal
action i've heard today that dockers in
hull out of sympathy with the rmt
members who've lost their jobs are
refusing to allow a ship to sail today
thank you very much for joining me this
afternoon mr corbin thank you